Richard Simmons hospitalized when the  King gets depressed he doesn't call for  his wife or the cook he calls for the  little man with a pointed hat and he  says to the court jester make me laugh  and I in that court jester the fitness  guru hasn't been seen out publicly in  years and now the 68 year old has been  taken to an undisclosed hospital in  California Simmons manager tells ET that  the star has been battling severe  indigestion and discomfort while eating  for a few days it's unclear what kind of  treatment Richard is undergoing or how  long he'll be hospitalized back in March  Richards brother Lenny told ET as far as  he knew his brother was healthy I can't  tell you that we talk every Sunday he  calls me and we have a great  conversation  you